The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
--do is talk a bit
about the politics of regulation
and a bit more about EPA
and how it works and
how it has worked.
Just by way of why are we doing
this in a course on energy
policy, an awful
lot of energy policy
is set by environmental
regulation.
All the-- much of the
discussion of doing
CO2 controls for climate
change comes down
to shaping energy policy.
So you really do need to
think about the environmental
regulation when thinking
about where energy is going
and where energy
policy is going.
And we'll talk about
a trading regime.
We talked about cap and
trade earlier briefly
when we talked about
climate change.
We'll talk about it in the
context of SO2 in the case
you've all read and
subsequent developments,
and then say a little bit
about generally what the--
how the regime looks.
It's worth stepping
back a minute just
to relate to some of
the earlier discussions
we had about politics
and interest groups.
I like the Wilson piece
because it splits politics
into recognizable categories.
I had a little
trouble, I confess,
as a non-political
scientist getting my head
around Lowy's four categories.
Wilson's are easy.
Who bears the costs?
Are they concentrated?
Who bears the benefits?
In the case of where the costs
of regulation are concentrated
and the benefits of
regulation are concentrated,
you get classic interest
group competition.
Cargos between US ports have
to be carried in US ships
by very long-standing law.
Those rights are regulated
by the-- those US
flagships wouldn't
exist but for that law.
This really affects
people who live in Hawaii
and who get cargos
from the mainland.
There are a small
number of shippers.
number of customers.
They're regulated by the
Federal Maritime Commission
that you've never heard
of, and they care a lot.
And that is the ultimate
inside baseball.
So that's maritime regulation.
Client politics is where the
benefits are concentrated
and the costs are dispersed.
And there's a lot of that.
We talked about concentrated
versus dispersed interests,
milk price supports.
A small number of milk
producers benefit, the costs
are dispersed among consumers.
In the old days of
airline regulation,
it sort of looked like that.
The reverse-- then he
talks about majoritarian,
where like antitrust, where
you really can't identify
the benefits and the costs.
They're both quite dispersed.
The interesting case, and
the case we have today,
is where the costs
are concentrated
and the benefits are dispersed.
And by our earlier
discussions of what
shapes interest group influence,
that shouldn't happen.
And the examples of
that are cases where
there was a social movement--
EPA.
The Food and Drug
Administration came out
of scandals in the early
part of the last century.
And you can talk about
a lot of regulation
that has that
character, but that
comes from a social movement.
He calls it
entrepreneurial, and that's
because usually an entrepreneur
drove the movement.
So it's useful to think
about sort of where
the regulation came from.
It's also useful to
think about, who does it?
Does anybody recall
the types that Wilson
has of people who work
in regulatory agencies?
Why would you work in
a regulatory agency?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's safe [INAUDIBLE].
Like, it's very--
it doesn't oscillate
as much with the market.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So you
might make a career out of it.
You might say, I want to
work in the Food and Drug
Administration as
opposed to a drug company
because it's really
safe and it's steady.
OK.
So that's the usual
civil service argument.
Any other reason?
David?
AUDIENCE: Ideally
because you care
a lot about the environment
in whatever you're doing.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
You might care a lot
about what you're doing.
So you might be a--
I guess an advocate,
which isn't quite what--
quite one of his categories.
Anything else you might--
any other reason you might--
Ryan?
AUDIENCE: Work with
political leaders.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You
work with political leaders.
You might have
political ambitions.
It doesn't arise
so much at the EPA,
but it can arise
in other settings.
You might also-- this is kind
of obscure, but you might--
why would an economist go to
work for the antitrust division
in the Department of Justice,
or a lawyer, for that matter?
To build a professional
reputation and then move out.
So Wilson talks about
careerists, politicians,
and professionals.
Careerists are those who
really believe in the agency.
And they're David's people who--
you work for the EPA because
you care about the environment.
Politicians want to go
someplace with that,
make contacts, and move on.
And professionals, lawyers,
want to gain status.
You want to be a
Washington lawyer,
you work for a Washington
agency, and you get known.
Who worked in the EPA early
on, who would you guess?
David?
Who would work for the
EPA when it starts?
AUDIENCE: People who care a
lot about the environment.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: That
means, and it's still true,
that you know how the
EPA thinks as an agency.
EPA favors tight rules.
EPA favors vigorous enforcement
because of the people
who were there.
Think about the
Department of Energy.
Why do you go to work for
the Department of Energy?
Well, you'd like reliable,
abundant supplies of energy.
You care about that.
Maybe you want to move
into the energy industry.
EPA-- you may want
to move into one
of the environmental groups.
The Department of
Energy-- you know how
they think going into the room.
If you have a meeting with EPA
and energy, as I had many of,
you know.
You don't have to
know who they are.
You know where
they come from, you
know how they think because
you know why they got there.
One needs to think about this.
Recall when we talked
about biodiesel at MIT.
We talked about what
do those people do?
What is their job?
What is their responsibility?
You didn't have to
know them to know
how they'd act in a meeting.
You had to know where they sat--
where they sat.
Where you stand depends
on where you sit.
OK.
Just talking now about
EPA, they do water, toxics
of various kinds, regulation.
Mostly what we care
about here is air.
They set national air
quality, ambient air quality
standards for six pollutants--
ozone particulates,
carbon monoxide,
oxides of nitrogen,
SOx and lead.
All of them-- because the
lead came from leaded gasoline
primarily-- are
driven by energy use.
So those standards
and other regulations
set energy policy, in effect.
The law requires
them to set standards
to protect human health with
an adequate margin of safety,
which presumes a threshold.
People have said for
30 years and more,
there aren't any thresholds.
The law presumes thresholds.
As we discussed last
time, they control--
they review state
implementation plans.
The reference to MIT parking
is to remind me to tell you
that the Massachusetts
state implementation
plan limits the number of
parking spots MIT can have.
And one of the reasons
there's a large garage
under this building is that
MIT wasn't using its limit
and was afraid the
limit would be lowered.
So state implementation plans
can go into great detail
and are reviewed by the EPA.
We talked about taxes
to limit pollution.
EPA has never done that.
They do-- early on they
did very little trading.
We talked about
offsets and so forth.
I'll come back to
that in a second.
Mostly, they set standards.
Most regulation is so many
grams of this, per unit of that,
or use this technology.
The economist's alternative
is put a price on it,
or limit its amount and let
people trade the right to emit.
When might a standard be better?
Why might a standard be
better in some cases,
not to be too dogmatic?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Well, standard,
you're-- you leave the option
for the specific
solution to be localized.
So if a specific-- is it all
just setting how exactly how
they should go about--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, that's
a standard versus a technology.
How about a standard
versus a tax or trade?
Because a standard tells
you what you must achieve--
doesn't necessarily
tell you how.
That's an interesting
distinction.
Tell me about why you--
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
So for example, cap and
trade, you can get--
when you establish cap and trade
or some sort of taxing, like,
you can still--
you're still not going to limit
the amount of pollution, right?
So if for whatever
reason, a specific region
has a lot of credit,
they can still
overpollute, as long as they
get their qualifications
in other ways.
So I think--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So
let me just cut you there.
What you're saying
is, it doesn't--
you can have intense
pollution in some areas.
Now, for carbon dioxide that
isn't going to matter, is it?
Because it mixes.
But it might matter
if it doesn't mix.
So suppose you have a pollutant
that basically travels
50 feet from the plant.
Then you wouldn't
want to use trading
from plants and
widely separated areas
because you'd have a hotspot.
OK.
So standards can
deal with hotspots,
and that's called
the hotspot problem.
You had a comment, Jacqueline?
AUDIENCE: Is there any
hazardous substances?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
that's the same issue.
Hazardous substances,
you might just--
if they're really hazardous,
you might want to ban them.
And if they don't travel--
all that stuff's
hazardous, to some extent.
If they don't travel
and they don't mix,
then you don't want to
say an emission here
is equivalent to
an emission there.
Lots of emissions here, and none
there is the same thing as none
there and lots there.
It may not be true.
People may live over
here, and not over there.
So that's the hot spot problem,
where things don't mix.
Any other reason why
you might want to--
suppose you couldn't
measure emissions very well.
Like automobiles-- we don't do
cap and trade for automobiles.
Can we measure what comes out
of the tailpipe of your car?
Not real easily.
We can measure per mile when
you go to get it inspected.
But it's-- aside from
monitoring your driving,
putting a meter
on your tailpipe,
we couldn't do cap and trade.
We can't measure it.
So there are enforcement
issues, right?
If I say to the
power plant, you have
to put this device
on your smokestack,
and it has to be working
when our inspectors come,
that's easy.
I can go check that.
That's why EPA-- one reason EPA
loves standards, particularly
technology standards.
Do you have the box?
Is it working?
Easy.
Not, how many tons
did you produce?
Did you run it the
daytime or night?
So there are enforcement issues,
and there are hotspot issues.
Let me see.
Is there anything
else you can think of?
Did anybody look at the
Sandel piece that's on it
and recommended?
Probably not.
It's late in the semester.
Sandel argues that
none of us would
agree that you ought to
be able to buy a license
to dump garbage in the street.
So he would say--
even if we could
do that, we could
have licenses to just dump
garbage in the street.
But we'd all sort of
think that's wrong.
If you could buy the right to
dump garbage in the street,
you'd eliminate the stigma.
And if you eliminate the
stigma, you eliminate a force
for cleaning up.
So Sandel would say it's
wrong to do trading because it
sort of eliminates the stigma.
Now, carbon dioxide versus
hazardous chemicals--
you may want to argue whether
a stigma is appropriate
as we breathe out CO2.
Maybe that's not such a
terrible thing to be doing.
But the other issue
you might think about--
if I can put a device on
the smokestack and I'm done,
I get no credit
for doing better.
So I get no credit for beating
a standard if a standard is set.
So there's no
reason to innovate.
If you've told me
that all I have
to do to comply with the
law is x, then I'm done.
If you tell me it costs $5
a ton every time I emit,
I have a constant incentive to
figure out ways to avoid it.
So standards ease enforcement.
They avoid the hot spot problem.
Environmentalists don't
like markets traditionally
because they like the stigma,
which I guess would apply--
I think makes more sense
in the case of toxics
than in the case of CO2.
Plenty of people would
like to stigmatize SUVs.
It raises costs-- may raise
costs, which we talked about.
We'll come back to.
And there's no reward
for innovation.
There's no reward for
beating the standard.
OK.
A little bit about
early trading, which
is in the text assignment.
Let me just mention this.
This is before 1990.
Did we have any trading
allowed in the US
apart from the lead phase-out?
Well, there were a few.
Netting says you can
go to your regulator.
You have an oil refinery.
Emissions here are regulated and
emissions there are regulated--
different parts of
the same factory.
And you say to the
regulator, look,
I'd really like to emit a little
more here in exchange for a lot
less there, or maybe it's even.
That's called netting.
It's in the same
internal transactions
or within an entity,
within a plant.
External transactions
are outside.
These are inside.
They happened,
thousands of them.
Offsets-- I think
we talked about.
Offsets are, I'm going
to do more than is
required in my factory--
or less than is
required in my factory,
in exchange for which he'll
do a lot more than is required
in his factory.
He'll do more than
he would have done.
And those are very
complicated negotiations
that happen in Los
Angeles heavily,
because you couldn't
build in Los Angeles.
You couldn't add anything
new in Los Angeles
unless you shut something down.
So if you happen not to
have anything to shut down,
you did a deal.
And the local
regulators would either
approve it on the grounds
that you were actually
reducing emissions over there
more than would have happened
or they'll disapprove it.
Because what the typical thing
is, you take an old factory,
and you pay them to shut down.
And the regulator would say,
but that's an old factory.
It would have shut down anyway.
So prove to me it
wouldn't have shut down
if you hadn't paid it.
Well, that's either impossible
if the burden of proof
is set high, or easy
if it's set low.
Bubbles are where
you take an area,
and you worry about
emissions within the area.
You put a bubble over it.
Some experiments were done.
Banking is where
I'll do more than I
have to today in
exchange for less than I
have to tomorrow-- very
little of that was done.
So these are kinds of trading
that the regulators fiddled
with early on, but
not in high volume
except for netting,
and not much impact.
So let us go to--
oh, one last thing
before I go to the case.
I want to say a little bit about
cost-benefit analysis, just
a very little bit.
We talked about it early on.
But it comes up sort of
in the case, sort of.
EPA has to produce a
cost-benefit analysis
of defending any
regulation at issues.
That's been a
requirement-- really,
the case talks about the
first sort of instances of it
under Carter.
It's been-- every president
has revised this rule
for executive branch agencies.
Usually, however, the
agencies make a decision
and then do a cost-benefit to
prove it was a good idea, which
drives other people crazy.
It's supposed to be
used to make a decision.
It's generally used
to defend a decision.
You never ever have
EPA produce a rule
and say, well, we have
to produce this rule,
but in fact, it has no benefits.
There's always a benefit.
Some controversies,
some of which
are mentioned in the text, EPA
having found carbon dioxide
emissions to be dangerous is
legally obliged to regulate it.
EPA has issued draft regulations
for new power plants.
Those regulations are being
challenged in court for,
among other reasons, being
arbitrary and capricious
because they will
have no benefits.
Regulation of carbon
dioxide from new US power
plants in a slow
growth period when
we're a small part
of the world will
have no detectable benefits.
True fact.
EPA is legally obliged to
issue a regulation, however.
It will be very
interesting to see
how the court rules
on this one, which
is now before the DC Circuit.
There are a set of
controversies about,
well, when you do a
cost-benefit analysis, what
discount rate do you use?
What do you-- do you
value carbon dioxide
emissions as a cost?
And how do you
value a life saved?
There are White House Office
of Management and Budget
directives on all of those that
tell agencies how to proceed.
You could imagine those are the
outcomes of significant fights
within each administration.
Another significant fight
is the senior discount,
which the text talks about.
And the way to
think about this one
is, do you count small particles
that are-- small particulates
that result from
sulfate emissions
cause acute respiratory episodes
under certain conditions.
Those tend to kill
elderly people.
So if you value the average
life saved at, say, $6 million,
how do you value the
life of an 85-year-old?
Some people say, well,
you shouldn't do lives,
you should do life years.
That 85-year-old is only
expected to live a few years.
If, in fact, you
killed a teenager,
you're costing a
lot more life years.
The EPA discussed this at one
point and proposed to do it.
That was the senior discount.
Who votes?
That proposal died.
I think most economists
think, although we're
a little uneasy about this, that
it sort of makes sense to ask,
are you killing somebody two
weeks early or 50 years early?
How you want to deal
with that difference
you can argue about for days,
but it sort of seems to matter.
But the 80-year-old votes,
so the senior discount
seems to have vanished from
government decision-making.
It appears all the time
in academic analysis.
Contingent valuation--
just one last topic.
It's not quite as hot a topic
as it used to used to be.
When we had the big Exxon
Valdez oil spill in Alaska
that was notorious, the question
was, what are the damages?
The damages were
mostly to wildlife
in the natural environment,
and nobody lived there
to a first approximation.
So it would be hard to
say that a lot of people
were directly damaged.
So if you ask-- loss
of fishing revenue,
$6; loss of campsites, $12.
So the following
technique was adopted.
They sent out a survey to
people in the lower 48 states.
How much would you be willing
to pay to undo the damage caused
by the Exxon Valdez?
And then they would
list a bunch of things.
And you get a really big number
when you ask that question
and add it up.
Because most people-- a lot
of people will pay zero.
That's the most common answer.
But among those people
who would pay something,
a standard answer is $20.
So since it's not real money,
you multiply that across 60,
70 million people, you get a--
and a few people will put out
$1,000, $2,000, $5,000--
you'll get hundreds
of millions of dollars
easily with a
question like that.
Does that mean anything?
This one was also in court
in a number of cases.
Does that mean anything?
One response to it was to
do surveys where they took--
they asked other people
the same kind of question,
but they doubled the
number of birds killed.
And then they asked other people
the same kind of question--
they cut the number of
birds killed in half.
That didn't affect the answers.
We say, oh, maybe
what I'm getting
is general environment
sentiment that has nothing
to do with this accident.
But then how do I value the fact
that there was enormous damage
to natural systems in wildlife
if I can't relate it to people
and the birds don't vote?
I'd say that remains
an unanswered question.
This notion of asking
people how much would you
pay to save a
million birds gives
answers that seem quite
unreliable, because you
get the same answer
for 1,000, and you get
the same answer for 10 million.
So you say, I don't
know what that means,
but I don't think
it's a real answer.
But then how do you
value the birds?
So a number of
questions, lots of fun.
Let's go to the case.
We passed the 1970
Clean Air Act amendments
and instructed EPA to do
a lot of things, including
the 1971 New Source
Performance Standard
for coal-fired generators.
We talked last time about who
were the interest groups review
the bidding.
Who was involved in
setting the '71 standard.
Who were the interest groups?
We did this last time.
Consult your memory.
AUDIENCE: Earth Day treehuggers.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: What?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Earth Day [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
treehuggers were very heavily
involved getting the act passed,
but you don't hear them much
mentioned in
connection with making
this administrative decision.
This was lobbying.
Who are the lobbyists?
EPA made the decision.
Casey?
AUDIENCE: The utilities
and the coal producers.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Were all the coal
producers in agreement?
AUDIENCE: No.
Because eastern coal
has a higher sulfur
content than western does.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So you had
eastern coal and western coal,
and I'm about to lead you
to the next question, which
is, why did that make it hard?
AUDIENCE: Because eastern
coal producers were afraid
that if EPA put a
standard in place
it required heavy emission
cuts without setting
a specific technology in
place to achieve those cuts,
and people would just switch
to using western coal instead
of eastern coal.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
That's the problem.
The coal in the US differs
dramatically in sulfur content.
There's a range,
particularly in the East.
It tends to be low in the West.
So if you say, you have to have
low emissions per kilowatt,
per megawatt hour,
kilowatt hour,
whichever, then
for a lot of people
it'll be cheaper to
switch to western coal.
If you say, what you
have to do is scrub--
that is to say, remove
sulfur from the exhaust,
then particularly if you say the
percentage you have to remove,
it may be cheaper
to use eastern coal.
And the people in the
west will go nuts.
If they're burning
really clean coal
and they have to also clean
the stack, they get angry.
So you have these two very
clearly opposed interests.
The ones in the east favored
a scrubbing standard.
The ones in the west favored
an emissions standard.
The '71 performance standard
was an emission standard--
1.2 pounds of sulfur dioxide
per million BTU burned, of coal
burned.
What was the cost-benefit
analysis behind that standard?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: People in the west
can burn their clean coal,
and they don't have to
do anything with it.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You're
giving me a political answer.
You're not giving
me the cost-benefit.
Did they do any cost-benefit?
Does the case mention any
analysis of costs or benefit?
No.
No, they didn't.
They just kind of
casually-- you're--
the answer they
gave was, you can
burn most-- you can
scrub most eastern coal
and meet that standard.
That was the thinking, which was
very, very casual, very casual.
This was challenged.
Does anybody recall what the
court challenge was all about?
Wyatt?
AUDIENCE: The
Navajo tribe sued--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Later case.
Later case.
The challenge of this one was--
AUDIENCE: It was
like the sludge.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: The
sludge challenge, yeah.
That EPA didn't
adequately consider
sludge that would
result. When you
take the junk out of the
emissions, you get sludge.
And you've got to treat
that or worry about it.
And it went back--
they didn't adequately
consider it,
and it was sent
back to consider it.
And they considered it,
and didn't change the rule.
The requirement isn't about
outcome, the requirement's
about process.
Did you adequately consider?
That requires somebody to
write something that says,
here's what they said.
Here's what we think about it.
Here's why it doesn't
change our conclusion.
You delegate that somewhere
down in the organization.
Deal with this.
Write me five pages.
OK.
Would you have
done anything else?
The case makes the
interesting point
that EPA was doing
a lot of stuff.
Congress does this all the time.
You set up a new agency, or
you pass a comprehensive law
like Dodd-Frank.
And you say to the agencies, we
need the following 5,000 rules
issued within 18 months.
And the agency says,
I've got six people.
And you do what you can, but
you don't spend your lifetime
on this one, because this is
new coal-fired power plants.
We've got this whole problem
with dealing with existing
sources with SIP plans.
What's a SIP look like?
What are SIP reviews,
State Implementation Plans?
What's all that about?
What are our air
quality standards?
And oh, by the way, we've
got to do this thing.
So they did it pretty casually.
Would you-- is it obvious that
there was a better approach?
Would you have done a
scrubbing standard, Casey?
I mean, you were--
AUDIENCE: I think I
probably would not have
done the scrubbing standard.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
You probably
would have done what they did
and said, yeah, this is OK.
We'll kick the
can down the road.
OK.
So this cruises.
This cruises along.
Now, Wyatt, what put
scrubbing on the table?
AUDIENCE: So the Navajos sued.
And they said if they had
made everybody install
scrubbing technology, the
people in the Southwest
would still buy the [INAUDIBLE]
coal because it's cheaper
to ship it, and then that would
overall reduce total emissions.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Would
reduce pollution in their area.
They were particularly worried--
maybe came a little later, but
they were particularly worried
at this point about haze.
And you still see
it in the West,
that you get a lot more
haze than you used to have.
And it's not hazardous to human
health, but it's obnoxious.
Haze in the Grand Canyon
means you just don't
have those wonderful views.
So the Navajos sued.
They lost.
The environmentalists-- the
other issue was the court.
Some states in the West
that were in full compliance
submitted state
implementation plans
that let them get
dirtier, but still
be in compliance with the law.
And the courts rejected those.
So what do you do about that?
Because you'd like to
develop in the West.
You'd like to grow.
You'd like to build stuff.
The court says, even if you're
clean, you can't get dirtier.
And people were installing--
the air quality
standards were nearby.
So one of the ways people were
dealing with sulfur dioxide
was to build these
monstrously high stacks, which
would just let the stuff
diffuse over a wide area.
So the standard which is about
concentration wasn't violated.
The environmentalists were
not happy, to say the least.
That just didn't seem like the
right approach to the problem.
That's take the dirt,
spread the dirt.
It's not too dirty
any place, see?
Same dirt, spread.
So everybody-- the Navajos
wanted stuff scrubbed.
The scrubbers were
a potential way
of dealing with this
Western states problem.
There may be other
ways, but in any case,
you had to go-- you
had to reopen the law
to deal with Western states,
to deal with that court
decision that basically didn't
let them build anything.
OK.
Who are the interest
groups here?
We're in-- we're now in
the process of writing--
it shouldn't say NSPS, it should
say Clean Air Act legislation.
So we go through
'76, '77 amending--
the process of
amending the bill.
And I left all that
stuff in the case
because it's interesting,
I think, to see it once,
to see the process of
trying to write something.
It gets passed here.
It gets rejected there.
The session ends.
You start over again.
You try.
Issues get debated
multiple times, often,
before things are
finally passed into law.
And this is an example.
There was the '76 process,
then there was the '77 process.
Who are the players?
AUDIENCE: Sierra Club.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Sierra Club,
or the environmental
groups, generally.
Notice they're not
marching in the streets.
They're lobbying.
So we've sort of seen the
environmental movement
transformed in
part into something
that looks more like a
conventional interest group.
They have lawyers.
The lawyers are in the details.
The lawyers are in the
lobby talking to people.
They threaten we could have
nine million people write
their congressmen about
this because we're
a grassroots organization.
So they're a little bit of
a social movement still,
but they're lobbying.
Who else?
Anybody else?
Environmentalists
wrote that law.
Coal producers fell asleep.
AUDIENCE: So I guess coal
producers in the East
would be--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Both sets--
East and West.
I mean, we're now back in play.
We're now back in play
worrying about scrubbing,
worrying about high-sulfur
coal, low-sulfur coal.
And of course, the people--
well, in the Western states.
Also the utilities.
I'm not quite sure why I
put the utilities there--
I didn't have the
utilities there.
But the utilities
are also involved
because they're going to
bear the cost of all this.
Scrubbing is not cheap.
So the question
of, do you scrub?
Don't you scrub?
Can you develop in the West?
OK.
Where was the Carter
administration?
You recall?
Yeah, Rory?
AUDIENCE: They wanted to spend--
solve energy problems, and to
do that easily they couldn't
sidestep the environment.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So
they were willing to scrub.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So
they wanted to scrub,
to sell the environmental
movement on the use of coal
for energy security.
If you made coal too
expensive, people
were still generating a
lot of power from oil,
and they really
wanted to move away
from oil for security reasons.
So, hey, scrubbing costs money,
but it's a security issue.
OK.
So you have the Carter
administration kind
of positioned in favor
of scrubbing, at least
at the White House.
You got Eastern coal that loves
scrubbing, Western coal that
hates scrubbing.
Environmentalists
have come to love it,
because it's now a
technology solution.
It's a standard.
It's the kind of thing
they tend to like.
Put the thing on the smokestack.
Make sure it's running.
That's swell.
Don't give me any nonsense.
The Western states say,
well, whatever you do,
we have to be able to grow.
We have to be able
to build things
in pristine areas, at
least some of them.
So what's the final outcome?
Well, we talk about the
outcome, but who favored it?
What did we get?
We got confused language, right?
We got confused language
as the final outcome.
And the confused language, if
you read that, and I actually--
I did this case out
of a larger piece.
I left out a lot of
detail because there--
this also happens.
Legislation goes to staff, and
you do not see senators at 3:00
in the morning rewriting
details of 1,000-page bills.
You see senators giving
instruction to people saying,
look, the bill has
to get this done.
And so at 3:00 in the morning
over pizza, people are saying,
well, let me just add this.
And then it goes from
the Senate to the House,
and somebody in the House
says, no, we can't have that.
Let me just take that out.
I'll put this in.
And then the bill gets passed.
And then somebody says, well,
but that doesn't read right,
so let me make sure
the report on the bill
says what we really mean.
And then somebody
else says, no, no, no.
So what you got in
this case was confused
language that sort of
seemed to favor scrubbing,
but was sufficiently
ambiguous to give some leeway.
Who liked that?
Who was in favor of that?
Who pushed-- who was happy
at the end of the day?
Who felt they'd won?
AUDIENCE: Western coal?
Because they weren't
shoehorned into using scrubbing
they didn't need.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Western coal, you're saying?
Nah, it kind of
favored scrubbing.
AUDIENCE: The
ambiguity-- ambiguity.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Oh, the ambiguity.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But they would rather
have had, oh, nothing--
that it's the administrator's
job to set a standard,
and the administrator
had done it once
and that was a
performance standard.
This now said the
administrator also has
to set a percentage removal--
doesn't say it has
to be positive,
but has to set a percentage
removal, has to consider costs,
has to set a
percentage removal, has
to at least look at scrubbing.
The earlier law didn't say
it had to look at scrubbing.
Who would like that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The utilities,
because [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Utilities sort of liked it.
Eastern coal sort of liked
it, because the Eastern coal
liked anything that
moved toward scrubbing.
And environmentalists liked it
because it favored scrubbing.
So that's the interesting
little irony, right?
I mean, you had
environmentalists
and Eastern coal favoring
the use of a dirty fuel.
That's an alliance.
And the great
quote in the case--
you almost never hear anything
like this, it's just amazing--
says, "It made sense for
the dirty coal producers
to abandon their campaign to
weaken standards and support
the most expensive possible
clean air solution,
universal scrubbing,"
which is what they
thought they got from Congress.
They thought they got
universal scrubbing.
You could read the law that way.
And this is a Sierra
Club-- a lawyer
on behalf of the Sierra Club.
He condemned that 1.2 pound
standard because, quote,
"Eastern high-sulfur coal,
which is now available,
is having a hard time
getting a market because
of the comparative
cheapness of bringing
in Western low-sulfur coal."
Eastern dirty coal
isn't selling well
because Western clean coal is
cheaper, says the Sierra Club.
OK.
This is a picture of politics.
People are getting what they
can get, building coalitions.
This is not the Sierra Club
trashing the environment,
this is the Sierra
Club pushing scrubbing.
The Sierra Club wants
scrubbing, and to get
scrubbing they have an alliance
with Eastern coal producers
who also want scrubbing.
You might say, gee,
wouldn't the Sierra Club
serve the environment better
if the Sierra Club said,
just tighten the standard.
Well, they weren't going to
get it because Eastern coal
producers were too strong.
So what they thought they could
get was scrub the dirty coal--
maybe cynical,
maybe not cynical.
Was it irrational?
Well that's-- people jumped
up and down about this.
What a bizarre alliance.
The environmental
interest groups,
arm in arm with the
dirty coal producers.
Well, they both got
what they wanted--
scrubbing.
Or they thought
they got scrubbing.
OK, I'll walk a little bit,
just in the interest of time,
through how we got to the New
Source Performance Standard,
because I want to spend
more time on 1980.
So what you had in the
administration was a split.
The air office says, these
guys won in Congress.
They went in trying to get
scrubbing, they got scrubbing.
Let's give them a scrubbing.
We'll set the New Source
performance Standard
as requiring 90% scrubbing.
The economists, always
the heroes of my story,
the Department of Energy, the
planning office in the EPA
said, why don't we just
tighten the standard?
The law says we have to
consider a percentage removal.
We'll make it zero.
Tighten the standard from
1.2 pounds per million BTU
to 0.55 pounds per million BTU.
You do it in the West,
with low-sulfur coal.
You do it in the East--
it's a little tough
to do it in the East,
but we're going to
tighten the standard.
That's the split within
the administration.
EPA's rules are reviewed
by the White House.
The Department of Energy
gets to sit at the table.
Everybody has fun.
Would require scrubbing, yes,
but not with Western coal--
not much scrubbing
with Western coal.
You could-- some Western coal
you could meet that straight.
Most of it you'd have to scrub.
But you wouldn't have to remove
90% of the sulfur to get it.
How had they shifted?
Well, this gets interesting.
The environmentalists could
count the 0.55 standard
as a win.
So they now didn't much
care about scrubbing.
What was on the table now,
both of those were wins.
The 0.55 would
probably be cleaner--
would be cleaner than 1.2.
So the environmental
movement switched.
Eastern coal wanted scrubbing.
The utilities, for some
reason that I don't quite
understand because
I didn't think
it was the cheapest
alternative, the utilities
sided with Eastern coal.
So you have a switch
when it went from passing
the law to making the rule.
The environmentalists
switched sides.
They were allied with the
Eastern coal interests
in the legislative process.
They switched in the
administrative process
as the agenda changed.
Again, this is not a picture--
this is kind of a particularly
striking case, which
is why it's here, and
it matters for energy,
which is why it's here.
But it's not that unusual
that interest groups switch
sides for tactical reasons.
This is-- there's no
religious issue here.
This isn't pro or anti.
This is, how do you get forward?
They wanted cleaner air
and they wanted scrubbing.
OK.
Once you get really
clean air, we'll
give up on scrubbing, let
the Eastern coal guys go.
The utilities now have a
distinct point of view.
The new NSPS, just
to go to it quickly,
we had a two-tier solution.
You could either scrub
90% and emit 1.2 pounds,
or you could scrub 70%
and emit 0.6 pounds.
It's a little weird
if you look at it.
Why not just require
these plants to be clean?
It's a political solution.
It made Eastern coal
economical in the East,
and Western coal
economical in the West.
Nobody's thrilled.
Not clear that those 70%
scrubbers actually work.
People have a tendency
to do this in Washington.
They've heard
about a technology.
They'll require it even if
it's not necessarily proven.
That's a political-- I
won't press you on that one.
What would you
have done instead?
Who knows?
It's a political answer.
OK.
Let me go-- after that,
let me pass out the B case.
New sources under this--
we talked about this--
under the '70 act and today
have to meet stricter standards
than old sources.
Old sources have to be
approved by the state.
There are plenty of really dirty
power plants still running.
So by the mid-'80s, this
is called new source bias
and leads to this wonderful
question on which I spent some
time in Washington, the outcome
of which I cannot remember
because it was so stupid.
What changes can you
make to an old plant
before it becomes a new plant?
The Environmental
Protection agency's position
was if you replace
a piece of capital
equipment like, oh, say, a
faucet, it's a new plant.
It's not the same as it was.
It's a new plant.
It has to meet new
source standards.
The Department of
Energy's position
was, well, if there's still
a brick from the old plant,
it's an old plant as long
as there's something left.
We reached a compromise
that was challenged in court
by both sides and upheld.
And I cannot tell
you what it was,
because that's a question
that has no answer.
What can you do in old--
that's-- there is no principled
answer to that question.
It's a compromise answer--
an enormous waste of time.
But in any case, so by the
mid-1980s, we had more than 80%
of the SO2 emitted was
emitted by power plants that
failed the '71 standard.
Because people-- and this
is ages of power plants.
We saw that at the
start of the semester.
There's an awful
lot of coal fired.
It's black, for
symbolic reasons--
a whole lot of old
coal-fired plants
put in place before 1970 still.
There were a lot more in 1985.
So all this hullabaloo about the
New Source Performance Standard
isn't actually going to do much.
You know, you're not huge growth
in capacity here in the '80s.
It's growing, but not rapidly.
So nobody-- people want to
extend the lives of old plants.
The old plants are dirty.
People aren't
building new plants.
And acid rain gets
to be an issue.
So acid rain says, particularly
with high smokestacks--
the stuff blows
hundreds of miles
was the argument, and damages
lakes in the Northeast.
So what do you do?
Well, in the '80s, what you
did was debate legislation that
required old plants to scrub.
And those laws didn't
get anywhere in part
because the costs
varied so enormously.
You have to have land
to put a scrubber in.
Some plants didn't
have any land.
They just have to shut down.
Does that make any sense?
And then the question
was, how are you
going to pay for
this monstrous thing?
How about we put on a
national electricity tax?
We didn't burn much
coal in New England,
so you could imagine the New
England response to that.
Let's see.
You're going to tax us
so Ohio can clean up.
Good idea.
Hmm.
No.
So the politics were bad.
And of course, the
Senate Majority leader
was from a Eastern
coal-producing state,
and the president
was Ronald Reagan.
So nothing was going
to pass, and nothing
was going to be signed.
But it was a question to do--
what do you do?
So that case, the B
case, which you have,
describes the
process that got us
to the trading position, the
trading provision, title IV,
in the 1990 Clean Air Act.
One environmental group, the
Environmental Defense Fund,
decided the only way we
could deal with this problem
was to put in place
trading, which
the environmental movement
had traditionally hated
because it removed stigma,
license to pollute, trading
and filth, et cetera,
markets and garbage,
all kinds of great slogans.
But once they saw there
was no other way to do it,
and we suddenly had a Senate
Majority Leader from Maine who
cared about acid rain, and
a president who had a summer
home in Maine who
cared about acid rain,
we were going to get a bill.
So this was the way forward.
It was a wild scramble
for the tradable things.
I was involved in this.
It was horse trading
at its worst,
but didn't affect
equal marginal costs.
We talked about national
trading for some pollutants.
It doesn't make sense
for all pollutants
because of the hotspot problem.
But in any case, this law, which
was a national cap and trade
for sulfur dioxide,
which by the way,
doesn't mix like carbon dioxide.
It doesn't mix around the globe.
It travels maybe a
few hundred miles.
Sulfur dioxide emitted
in Miami does not
affect the forests
in Maine at all--
affects the oceans, but doesn't
affect the forest in Maine
directly.
And sulfur dioxide
emitted in Arizona,
boy, there may be a few
molecules who get east,
but not that-- that get
east, not that many.
So it took effect in 1995.
So we're now after that B case.
If you have any questions
about it, about the case,
let me know.
I've got a bit to
cover, and I want
to make sure I get it done.
So here's what happened--
one thing that happened.
The law created an asset,
this tradable allowance,
and it gave it away.
Now that's interesting, right?
That's interesting.
It gave away the rights
to emit sulfur dioxide.
Now, if it were a
competitive market--
let's suppose it took
one of those things
to generate a megawatt
of electricity.
Then you'd expect the
price of electricity
to rise by the cost of an
allowance on opportunity cost,
on an opportunity cost basis.
If you give it to me for free,
but if I don't use it myself
I can sell it--
so the cost of using it is
the price on the market,
even though I got it for free.
So what you would expect
is in a competitive market,
it's a gift.
In a regulated market,
it's not so clear.
And states had different
ways of dealing with this.
This picture illustrates
sort of the distinction
between the value
of the allowances
and the cost of cleanup,
which is often a confusion.
So we have allowances
to emit sulfur dioxide.
Each one gives you the
right to emit a ton.
There's a demand for those.
What's the demand determined by?
Well, it is determined by the
marginal cost of cleaning up.
If this is what I would emit--
this is what the industry
would emit if there
were no price on allowances.
And this is what they emit
when the price is higher.
This curve must reflect the
marginal cost of cleanup.
Because you will emit
until the cost of cleanup
exceeds the costs or the--
you'll clean up until
the cost of cleanup
exceeds the value
of an allowance
because I have a choice.
I can reduce emissions
or buy an allowance.
So the area-- if this is the
cap, the area under the curve
to here, and if
this is the price,
this area must be
the cost of cleanup.
Just like the demand for a good
is the marginal value consumers
place on it, here the marginal
value is the cost of cleanup.
So the cost-- the area under
this curve from here to here
is the cost.
This rent is the value of the
allowances that were given out.
Now, if this were a
competitive, unregulated market,
and that picture were right--
well, I don't have the rest of
the story so I can't say that.
Normally, however, it's a gift.
You probably haven't
followed this,
but there's a controversy about
the European carbon trading
system is now being expanded
to include airlines, which
requires airlines flying
into Europe to buy allowances
to cover the carbon
they emit flying in.
Airlines, including US airlines,
are being given allowances.
Not enough, but they're
being given allowances
to cover most of
their emissions.
The US airlines are
berserk about this.
The administration is
You're taxing our people.
The analysis done
over in Building E19
concludes very persuasively that
the US airlines will, in fact,
make money because they're being
given almost enough allowances,
and the price of
airline fares is
going to go up to cover
the opportunity cost--
not the out-of-pocket
cost, the opportunity cost.
Even if I've been given it,
the cost of using it to me
is the market price.
The price I charge will
have to cover that.
My profits will go up.
US airlines hate this analysis.
They paid for it.
They now reject it
as fatally flawed.
It is, if you think about it
for a little while, pretty
simple economics, a little more
complicated under regulation.
So what else happened?
Question on this?
OK.
What else happened?
Well, this is the
pretty picture.
These were-- this was actual
emissions, US emissions
in millions of tons.
These were-- you can estimate
that pretty well by the fuel
they burned.
After 1995, they had
monitors on the stack,
so we know it for sure.
Here's the cap, this line here.
It went down over time.
It's a little complicated
because more units were
covered, which is one reason--
a lot of things happened,
but this is the aggregate cap
pretty clearly.
These are some
estimates of what might
have happened absent the law.
The law was passed
in 1990, but there
was some anticipation of it
and some investments made.
But the key thing
is in the oval.
Look at what happened
to emissions.
Environmental programs
don't do that.
People litigate.
They resist.
The devices don't work.
Look at that drop.
It dropped below the cap--
way below the cap.
Why did that happen
do you think?
Well, I'll give you the--
yeah, go ahead, Jacqueline.
AUDIENCE: Was it banking?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
It was banking.
Exactly.
There was banking.
The cap gets pretty low out here
around 2,000 A lot of people
said, all right, I'm
going to look to 2,000.
I'm going to overcontrol.
I'm going to do more
than I need to do now,
so that when I come here,
I can notice emissions
are above the cap here.
I can draw down the bank.
I can draw down.
And that makes sense?
Yeah, it probably made sense.
Because you got early
emissions reductions.
You got early control.
Cumulative emissions
were the same.
Eventually, the
bank is exhausted.
The other thing you saw,
this business about always
having an incentive to cut.
The incentive to cut
here was the value
of the banked
allowance later on.
The other thing that
happened that you
wouldn't have had happen in
standards is people innovated.
Well, you know how I'm talking
about burning high-sulfur coal
and burning low-sulfur coal.
People say, wait a minute.
High-sulfur coal
is now really cheap
because it's really dirty.
But I can mix it.
It's not a trivial thing to
do, but it's not that hard.
People figured out
how to blend it in,
which lowered their costs while
still keeping under allowances.
People invented
new ways to scrub.
Didn't remove 90%,
but were lots cheaper.
People did a variety of things.
Railroad deregulation
brought Western coal east.
So we had this huge
reduction in emissions,
and you saw it on the ground.
Now, it turns out acid
rain wasn't as damaging
as people thought.
There was a large study
funded on impact of acid rain.
It wasn't finished before
the bill was passed--
hey.
But in terms of deposition,
you saw a great reduction
in the Northeast--
still some hot
spots, but nothing
like what they were before.
This was why the fiction worked.
It was going to be
cheapest to control in here
and everybody knew it.
So if you had-- even if you
had a national regime, and yes,
you could control down here.
You can control over there.
You can control up here.
It was going to be cheapest
to make reductions here.
And so that's where they
were going to get made.
All the models said that.
Everybody was very
quiet about the fact
that this stuff doesn't mix.
Because the models
were pretty clear
that we're going
to get what we want
because here's where
it's cheap, and here's
where we want the cuts made.
But the different-- but
the point to keep in mind
is even in these regions,
the costs of control
differed enormously
among plants.
So yeah, regionally
it's cheapest in there,
but not plant by plant.
So trading worked.
It got it where it was cheapest,
and where it was cheapest
was where we wanted it.
This is the price.
These are the price
of these rights
to emit a ton running
through the end of 2003.
The initial estimates
were higher.
were about $300 a ton.
So some mixture of innovation
and cheap Western coal
held the price down.
But you will notice the
price bounces around.
People were making a living
trading these things.
How could you make a living?
Well, why did they bounce?
Well, if you think about
it for just a minute,
it's sort of like
we talked about oil.
There's a demand for emissions.
It depends on the economy.
It depends on coal prices.
It depends on a lot of things.
But in the short run,
it's pretty inelastic--
short run, a few months.
You don't change a coal
plant in a few months.
The supply curve is
that vertical line.
It's a cap.
So the supply is
really inelastic,
the demand is pretty inelastic,
and the price bounces.
So if you look at it,
you say, well, all right.
The price moved from,
say, $75 to $200
over a period of a few years--
terrible, horrible.
Oh, by the way, there
were speculators.
Of course there
How could there
not be speculators?
Did the speculators do this?
Not really.
They may have amplified,
but the main story
was inelastic demand
and inelastic supply.
Industry hated this,
as you could imagine.
Not such a big deal for sulfur
because it's a small cost,
but makes it hard
to plan when you
don't know within
a factor of three
what that cost is going to be.
The alternative--
and I will say we
were asked a lot,
those of us who
were involved in doing this
thing, why didn't you do a tax?
Tax would avoid that
kind of uncertainty.
You buy-- the government
would buy or sell.
You just put it-- in effect.
You just put a tax
on SO2 emissions.
Wouldn't that be better?
Yes and no.
It would mean there was a risk--
the risk would transfer, as
you can see, to quantity.
The environmentalists
hated that.
You don't know how much
is going to be emitted?
Rather not know the price.
And the utilities
really hated it
because instead of being
given these rights,
you'd actually have
to pay out of pocket.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
So that was a non-starter.
That was a nonstarter.
OK.
Let us now go--
I think this is where we go--
to the C case.
So what the C case
tells us is the game
shifted in the early '90s.
People worried less
about acid rain,
and they worried a lot more
about small, fine particulates.
Began to get
epidemiological studies
that said that fine
particulates kill people.
Mostly they kill old
people, but old people vote.
So EPA had to--
EPA issued a standard for
fine particulates in 1997,
and it had to figure out how to
meet that standard, the problem
being the acid rain problem
in different clothing.
Small particulates are caused
by SO2, among other things,
and thus, they travel.
In effect, they travel.
So EPA, which has
interstate authority,
had to do something
about fine particulates.
So what it tried to do
was brilliant in a way.
It said, we'll tighten
the acid rain program.
How do we tighten the
acid rain program?
We require I think it was two
allowances to be emitted now
for every ton instead
of one allowance.
How perfect is that?
We just cut the ceiling--
cut the cap in half.
Surely that's going
to reduce emissions
enough to cut these
particulates way back.
Well, here's what
happened to prices.
Yeah.
What I showed you early
on, ran up to about there.
This drastic tightening
was being debated.
And that must be somebody
cornering the market,
but run-up--
or trying to.
But the run-up to the shoulders
was fear of this regulation.
So again, if you
read the C case,
this was a brilliant idea to
keep the trading system intact,
to make it deal with the new
problem by tightening it.
If you want to read-- oh, I
didn't put the citation in.
If you want to read
something really depressing,
read the circuit
court opinion that
dealt with the maybe 40 people
who challenged this rule.
Hundreds of reasons
why you couldn't
do this, why it was
arbitrary and capricious
and an abuse of discretion.
And what the court
did was throw it out.
And by throwing it out, threw
out the acid rain program.
You see the little
quotation there.
It said, "Sources in
Alabama which contribute
to nonattainment of the
fine particulate standard
in Davidson County,
North Carolina
would not need to reduce
their emissions at all."
They could just buy
the right to emit.
"Therefore, they could keep
contributing to nonattainment
in North Carolina.
Therefore, a rule that
allows that is invalid."
It doesn't solve the
North Carolina problem.
You've got to come up
with something that does.
And what EPA has come up
with and what's in process
is something that basically
eliminates interstate trading.
So this is the short happy
life of interstate trading
of sulfur dioxide allowances.
It worked.
It didn't in the
eyes of the court
solve the next problem that
came along, but it worked.
So let me say a little bit
generally about the Clean Air
Act from some EPA propaganda.
Stepping back from
this program--
and I'll let you
digest this stuff,
and we'll have a few
minutes for questions.
If you look over the long
term, from 1970 to 2005,
real GDP almost doubled.
Vehicle miles traveled
almost doubled.
Lead emissions went
almost to zero.
Well, that was easy.
We phased lead out of gasoline.
That was a good trick.
But large particulates
went down by 83%,
but the small
particulates not so much.
So this problem
is still with us.
The small particulates
turn out--
the big ones you see.
The small ones kill
you, as a shorthand.
Carbon monoxide is down
better more than half.
Sulfur dioxide is down half.
Oxides of-- these are national
emissions, not concentrations.
Oxides of nitrogen-- 30%.
That's stubborn because you
get it from automobiles,
and you got that doubling
of vehicle miles traveled.
But still down a third.
Volatile organics down 52%, and
that's catalytic converters.
So if you look at that--
again, if you look at that
relative to that paper that
was so pessimistic about
environmental progress,
that's not bad.
If you hadn't had EPA,
it would have been worse.
Most of this stuff
would have gone up
with GDP or vehicle
miles traveled.
Not great.
You still have ozone, which
involves small particulates--
stubborn, stubborn-- the
Eastern Seaboard, and of course,
Southern California.
But you'll notice Cape Cod
is a nonattainment for ozone,
not because of the
terrible things
they do there, because it moves.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's a
random [INAUDIBLE]??
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
The random what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: In Colorado.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
In Colorado?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: That, I
believe, is carbon monoxide,
and it has to do with
automobiles I think.
I don't think it's ozone.
AUDIENCE: Is there an
Air Force base there?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
No, no, no, no, no.
This is Denver.
Do you have a clue what that is?
I know there was some there
was some issues with fuel
formulation there in particular.
So I think it's a--
it is a-- I think it's an ozone
or a carbon monoxide problem.
I could be wrong.
But there are people there.
There are people there.
It's not just skiing.
Skiing's farther west.
So there are parts of the
country where the air still
counts as dirty.
And that's ozone and other
criteria pollutants are, again,
in some places.
You've got the-- well, some
of these are quite unpleasant.
Southern-- not unpleasant,
but Southern California,
for instance, persists,
as for that matter,
does the Pittsburgh
area in nonattainment
for a number of pollutants.
So let me pause there.
That's a lot of ground to
cover and I rushed through it.
So let me see if you have
questions on any of it.
Oh, yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you
go back one slide?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Absolutely.
That's easy.
AUDIENCE: So in California,
like, along the border
of California and
Nevada, it looks
like pretty much all of
that border in California
is really bad.
But then in Nevada it's
only at the southern tip.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I think
what you have here is--
is this maybe Imperial
County, which is gigantic?
So it may be that the
problem is over here.
So it's being done by county.
It's being done-- there's
certain monitoring
stations in each county.
And my guess is Death
Valley is probably
not a nonattainment
area for much.
But over here near
LA, I'm guessing.
AUDIENCE: Part of the county.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
Yeah.
It's a certain
number of monitoring
stations sort of thing.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you [INAUDIBLE]?
Like, what would happen if you
had like a quantity control
up to, say, 80% of the
cap and then set a tax?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Sure.
Sure.
You could even do
better than that.
Let me get there.
Yeah, here.
Oh, or here, but rather here.
What people did talk about
in the context of CO2--
so we talked about there
was a cap and trade bill.
And environmentalists
said, well,
the price could get so low there
wouldn't be any incentives.
And industry said,
the price could
be so high it would kill us.
If we had sudden
economic growth,
we could get really high prices
that would choke off growth.
Or if the growth
was slow, you could
have what you have in
Europe, which is really
slow prices, really low prices.
So people proposed, how about
we have a floor and a ceiling?
The floor would be if the
price drops below this floor,
some agency starts buying
these things on the market.
If the price gets
above the ceiling,
we start selling them
at the ceiling price.
So you stand ready to
buy at the floor price
and sell at the ceiling price
to limit the fluctuations.
And if the floor and
ceiling are close enough
together it looks like a tax.
So that was a serious
set of proposals
in the climate context
for exactly the reasons I
think you're thinking of.
Too low removes incentives;
too high is very expensive.
You give up quantity
control, but you give up
quantity control
sort of at the edges.
If growth is really slow, then
emissions are going to be low.
The problem is up here,
if growth is really fast,
you're going to let
emissions grow some.
So maybe you want this curve
to be steep up here, a supply
curve.
But you could-- there
are very-- there
are ways to combine these two
and variations on a theme.
Yeah.
Anything else?
OK.